big and silvery there's just really
nothing like it big silver scales on the
side of their Amaral with a huge eye up
in the head call the silver king this
shiny Atlantic Beast can reach eight
feet long and weigh over 350 pounds
tarpon are so well adopted to grow and
thrive they remain relatively unchanged
since the time of the dinosaurs the
fossil record of Tarpons goes back a
long way we think we have fossils of
karpin's that are a hundred million
years old for millennia
tarpon growth has come down to survival
of the fittest females spawn millions of
eggs each year only a fraction make it
to adulthood but those super specimens
that do survive are built to last living
for 50 years or more feeding and growing
to mammoth proportions with few natural
enemies being big allows them to escape
the threats of predators and it lets
them move into the open water where they
can hunt for bigger prey one boost to
their big size the tarpon is a Night
Stalker born with nature's answer to
infrared technology this unusual ability
is thanks to enormous eyes that work
like highly sensitive light absorbers
giant lenses capture every luminescent
particle in the water
maximizing reflections isolating moving
shapes helping tarpon homed in on prey
in deep waters it's a huge scene and
Stocking advantage allowing tarpon to
snag fish other predators miss ambushing
a meal with ease
- fisherman tarpon are extraordinary
prize fighters one of the oceans
toughest opponents
sweet
they carry the worldwide reputation of
the king of all for taste they're so
incredible fighting fish